[Music]
in privacy please news privacy's yeah
submitted by tiger from the future
[ __ ] homework [ __ ] future Micah come
on man tha i'ma beat your ass when I go
home [ __ ] up in the future
[ __ ] yourself own porn habit
isn't as secret as you think why cuz the
[ __ ] stains on your seat my fruity is my
rubidium on blackberry I never had a bit
loose at again the BlackBerry chat
blackberry messenger bbm yeah and it
usually shows on top like like Bart is
now listening to the song from the
Hollywood it does that yeah my friend
was watching porn didn't really you can
turn it on and off you know turn it off
and it said bunny blah is watching
[ __ ] come throwers for right now and
then I message I was like yo piranhas
mmm oh [ __ ] sorry it's awesome I don't
understand why my porn sites have a
share to Facebook yeah why have anyone
maybe I want to share with your friends
when is everyone and like anyone ever
shared it you know those porn groups and
stuff I don't know there's porn groups
right or tweet it you know am I making
this [ __ ] up yeah I been to porn groups
and I found out in a very disturbing way
I'll explain the story please good my
dad on Facebook and you kept liking all
these like have like some disturbing s
titles and Spanish and I'm like dad I
sent him a message I'm like you know we
can see everything you're doing right
stop it
what did say he was like oh I'm sorry I
didn't know but that wasn't me he tried
saying it wasn't him
ya know just like okay unfriend and
delete that message and wipe my hands
clean on a brighter note at least that
still has his groove he needs to stop he
needs to stop his groove you're dating
like 20 years what's wrong with [ __ ]
like gum Fiesta for Quatro Quatro know
what [ __ ] in Spanish Feliz cumpleaños
Spanish beam in tonight's emo at least
compleanno x' oh my god come to Leon you
stop it that's a new floor demon like
when someone says something you'd be
like yeah for sure you really asking one
I got some Samoan all over me that's a
hobby say it no I don't know anything
it's not words that you bring up in
conversation with parents or people so
you don't really know not even slang let
me google it because I didn't know how
to say vagina in Korean until my friends
told me what is it Butchie chunji
challenge or like private parts is like
Cauchy key so that's not stuff that you
learn from your parents delicious didn't
see mom see man anyway see mein kampf
Leonia so this tech firm called wanderer
is shoot a warning says quote watching
mobile porn on your smartphone is a much
higher risk than watching it on your PC
what are you what are you people knowing
that you watch porn [ __ ] hi pleasure
phone operating systems especially you
got your back there saying that be
careful when you're watching anime porn
whoo yeah yeah they have really good
stories you share your Dragonball
[ __ ] yeah the thing about anime porn is
like they have the great storytelling
like a normal anime but there's sex
reward I like anime too much in general
to watch anime porn because the
animation is terrible cuz I tried
watching it when you mentioned it and I
was like alright let's just try to give
this a go because when I was in high
school that [ __ ] was [ __ ] weird
because it was like a bull demon [ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of them but the animation
is so bad and it's just like yeah what
are you risking so they're saying that
the smartphone operating systems
especially Android are not as secure as
desktops that there are many
vulnerabilities that can be easily
exploited by hackers where they can like
virus install Mart malware into your
pone yeah through a porn site so you're
just saying like just don't watch porn
on your phone even if you go in the
incognito [ __ ] um you know can be can be
fish on porn are not important on phones
maybe like you clicking Lincoln and
almost on Bob love fishy fishy like does
that happen on phones or stops I mean
and what is proxy mean
property is to like change think of it
like math when you shut up like
proximately think of it like Mac's
masking your location no way yeah so
then when they were doing that thing
with our phones how come everyone was
saying that they were proxy as in like
they're masking their number with
someone else's some s of their
information and then what is fishy
bottle you know fishing which is a word
by the way it looked like pH yeah
fishing is like getting your your login
[ __ ] whatever like you click on
something
this rod and you throw it in the water
right you know you wait and you wait you
gotta put bait on it before you throw
sometimes you don't when you do pier
fishing a lot of macros just bite [ __ ]
for no [ __ ] reason you ever get those
emails or they're like hey this is
Instagram we got a double check
something so make sure type in your
password
those are like fishing people I like
those because I always respond I like
big [ __ ] six nine and they probably use
that pattern oh how many [ __ ] random
I get like different voicemails - it's
like a different form of the IRS saying
I [ __ ] up on something different so
apparently I just [ __ ] everything you
know I mean it's like the FBI is after
you doing what the cops are after you
and they want they're gonna be at your
door in two hours I'm like yeah I was I
was I was in an email you know how like
people don't know how to blind see see
someone there's like 30 emails on there
it's like oh this is Facebook your your
password but Victor but I respond I was
like how about you not messaged all 30
of us and the guys responded I messed up
sadface from Apple and then the bottom
adjusted hacker way come on man like the
address was hacker way all right and
then I'll get text messages what is it
whoa so they'll go to my email and try
to get like a password reset and the
code will be sent to my phone and then I
think like they they text me from some
phone number says a Google code was sent
to you blah blah blah duh respond with
that code now or be locked out of your
thing random numbers how come they just
don't go after people who have more
money right yeah I mean like what do
what are you gonna take for me bro yeah
I had to call you red just so I can have
clothes he gets nothing but debt and
payments of like payment plan
that's all he gets dead I bet you what's
gonna happen they're gonna hack my
account and they're gonna give me money
it's like you having a shitty car they
feel so bad for you that's like money
I've got that Tesla but you can't even
afford it
anyways so they're saying that 40 out of
the top so 40 out of the top 50 adult
sites are vulnerable to malware so don't
look at it 40 out of the 50 of the top
boil why is why why report sites so
shitty it yeah well they clean that [ __ ]
yeah like they make so much [ __ ]
money
hey boy I understand you make a lot of
money cuz people are just watching this
[ __ ] over and over one guy that you the
whole world can think for when it comes
to free porn he has some sort of license
or whatever for websites and stuff and
he decided to make porn just all free
for everyone on these sites and he just
makes money off the ads so that's why
there's free porn now streaming and then
those ads are the ones that give you the
network yeah I guess so I don't know why
don't [ __ ] clean up ads and [ __ ] porn
it's like a multi-billion dollar company
I mean like business I don't know why
didn't they don't just [ __ ] now
everyone's entitled about porn it's like
it should be free it's a human right
what cuz they're gonna give you know
people are so used to getting it for
free no you know if it's like it's like
water
we need porn to live I don't know why
people even pay for porn anymore I know
we sites it's like a teaser to like
branded content that's like oh I like
this [ __ ] [ __ ] a MILF and my
girlfriend at the same time site right
and then like where they show like one
video and like I want to see more so
then like they advertise it and then you
go to that site and it's all that so you
could have multiple different moms and
daughters [ __ ] yeah I feel like yeah
it like what does it ripped and then put
on the free sites anyways don't they but
don't you get directors commentary bonus
features theater sometimes like they
produce so much content that you can get
like a Hall Pass like you pay for one
monthly pass thing and then you get
access to like 10 sites so
it's like a lure like you they get you
in and then it's like you get better
content here I would like for somebody
to make a good documentary on porn stars
and stop picking the ones that are
[ __ ] dumbest [ __ ] and they can't
speak are you drugged out yeah pick the
ones that are actually doing something
Nick like like that you know what I mean
and they can kind of like walk through
the steps of how they got from point A
to point B because I've seen a couple
whatever like I forgot was on Netflix
and it's like the dumbest girls I don't
want to hear them speak ed there's
there's actually a lot of women and porn
that have college degrees and stuff too
I saw this it was kind of like top ten
women or whatever right Tara Patrick she
was a nurse or RN she was my favorite
who was a smart and a super [ __ ]
smart one that was it ASA
no no but it was a asian girl though and
she was actually has a master's degree I
forgot her name but she was more of like
an early 2000s girl and like like I know
a couple of them like attended Ivy
League schools and shoes yeah I'm smart
as [ __ ] but they did a what up all my
positive people I want to hear your
thoughts put it in the comments below
because if you're negative shut the hell
up and go drink some raid please but if
you're very positive leave it in the
comments below for the last video go
over here
you
[Music]